Aaron Sampson here not yelling yes I do
read your conference should you care
about Ghost Recon online being rebranded
phantoms yes yes you should are you a
unicorn I do the unicorn [ __ ] deal with
it because you're a unicorn
and you do unicorns and what is unicorn
it's a great cover based multi player
shooter for free yeah it's two years old
and maybe Ubisoft has added a little
polish and a few maps but the reason you
should really be playing this free game
is that it's great idea still hold up I
mean what are you gonna do go play a
future soldier instead titanfall okay
you're probably playing titanfall Ghost
Recon phantoms continues to do a number
of things really well that it's always
done well the cover mechanics are
multi-tiered in superb with low medium
and high stances the special abilities
of each of the three classes spar in fun
ways check this out that support guy
just popped his damage shield to charge
up the middle my assault class to poison
area-denial heat shield and shuts him
down then some other douche pops in EMP
and everyone's powers go away phantoms
also is a really good test range that
you can get you from almost anywhere in
the game when you're not in a match you
can try any weapon here whether you own
it or not and that helps you make really
important decisions on what to spend
your in-game points on or maybe drop
some real cash up to you oh and grenades
cost you these same points so they're
valuable and rarely spammed there's a
great multiplayer community here also
people seem to be on mic coordinating
attacks talking tactics baby being
jackasses but that's entertaining too
what I got shot in the face by the guy
that was flanking us he'll need a good
team to play phantoms take on conquest
which starts in the middle and works in
one of two completely different
directions you can play a map several
times and it'll feel different each time
you should care about Ghost Recon
phantoms because it's still well
supported by Ubisoft and you don't
really have to spend actual dollars if
you don't want to the slower pacing of
cover-based competition is refreshing
and hey you're a unicorn right go do
some unicorn while you're waiting for
the division